grimm is there chad what's going on
good evening sean well you know members
have been removed from committees before
but by their
own leaders kevin mccarthy the minority
leader in the house of representatives
he ousted steve king
two years ago john boehner when he was
speaker of the house back in 2012
he removed three republicans from
committees he basically didn't think
that they were being
team players but this is a little bit
different having the entire house do it
that's brand new here is jim mcgovern
the chair of the house rules committee
a member of this house is calling for
assassinations
that's the that's the new precedent and
as i said
you know if that's the standard
that we remove people from
committees i'm fine with that
republicans tried to return the favor
they introduced an amendment to strip
democratic minnesota representative elon
omar of her committee assignments
democrats ruled that amendment out of
order
just like it says in the bible if you
have a speck in your eye
that don't have don't criticize someone
for the spec in his life you've got a
log in yours
now steny hoyer the house majority
leader and kevin mccarthy they tried to
get a deal about greene and mccarthy put
out a statement tonight criticizing
democrats the house of representatives
will vote tomorrow to bounce green from
her committee it just takes a simple
majority
and at a republican conference meeting
late this afternoon
some republicans applauded and gave
greene a standing ovation
also a bit of breaking news here tonight
sean the house republican conference
has voted to keep liz cheney from
wyoming on
as the conference chairwoman that's the
number three leadership position
in the house republican conference to
vote there 145
to 61. sean all right chad thank you as
always